Dancing with the Stars fan favorite Kate
Flannery the office star is hilarious
and she is killing it in the ballroom so
could we see more dunder mifflin
employees following suit
well Kelsey Knight found out exclusively
at her dance in rehearsals who do you
think besides yourself would do great on
Dancing with the Stars from the office
cast and who do you think would be
horrific well I think Phyllis would kill
it probably Dwight wait what
he knows everything so he couldn't learn
fact fact fact speaking of facts Kate
had the second highest score last week
this is a champagne problem my friends
yes tonight it's movie night in the
ballroom so we had to ask when are we
getting the office movie I'm not the one
holding up the deal anytime anytime is
to call them out on Entertainment
Tonight Jenna I think Steve Carell is a
movie star and I don't blame him but
maybe he could be the star of the office
movie Steve people love Michael Scott
another fun fact this is Kate's Pro
partner Pasha's first season on the show
and he is a huge fan of the office it's
on a repeat that my house
non-stop what is your favorite office
episode course Kate and casual Friday
that was one of the worst hairstyle is
on television history and some of the
worst clothes and I missed them
desperately on the very first set visit
et went to the office everyone was
singing the et theme song Entertainment
Tonight
between takes all the time
Krasinski love
sorry about that you remember it of
course but I look back the entertainment
tonight it's a crazy show and you could
go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]